foreign
[Music]
by the way the road looks look I just
know that I've been here before I just
know that I've been stuck here
[Music]
everything's gonna be all right
I never thought I could make it as a
real model you know fashion oriented
modeling trying to make a living
isn't that right Mike what do you care
about money you got plenty of money
actually Mike is right I am going to
inherit money a lot of money you men
make yourselves comfortable I'll be
right back
cool he just likes to have three guys
because it takes her a little while to
get warmed up it's normal nothing kinky
it's not a normal family and I would
have been a well-adjusted person depends
on what you call normal yeah it does
she takes this gun sticks it in his
mouth and blows his brains out
that guy that guy is your real father
don't me in the head anymore man I
know who my real dad is who is
who you
you're my dad I know that
yeah
[Music]
I'm
extremely excited
[Music]
come on
I've been here on this street on this
Crusade
[Music]
almost four years that's a long time
River Phoenix
winner of the Volpe cup for best actor
Venice Film Festival 1991. Mikey my best
friend and it's good to be you know good
friends that's a good thing
Keanu Reeves when I turned 21 I don't
want any more of this life I will change
when everybody expects it the least
it probably goes all around the world
from the acclaimed director of Drugstore
Cowboy
my own private Idaho the new film by Gus
Van Sant
foreign
[Music]